good day everyone welcome happy friday
i'm jack van horn from the university
of virginia please allow me to welcome
you to this edition of our 2020 2021
of biomedical data science seminar series this
lecture series is supported by uva's integrated
translational health institute of virginia the uva
brain institute the college of arts and sciences
the school of data science and through a grant
from the national institutes of general medical
sciences it is my honor and privilege today to
welcome our speaker dr angela laird from florida
international university in miami florida dr laird
received her bachelor of science degree in physics
from florida state university in 1998 and her phd
in physics and medical physics from the university
of wisconsin-madison in 2002. as mentioned
dr laird was originally trained as an imaging
physicist but has transformed herself into a
cognitive neuroscience aiming to characterize the
functional organization of the human brain she was
a faculty member at the research imaging institute
of the university of texas health sciences center
in san antonio from 2004 to 2012 and is currently
an associate professor i think correct me
if i'm wrong angel yes sir bold professor
she congratulations in the department of physics
at fiu she's been recognized as a rising star at
the university of texas and is a top scholar um
at florida international university in 2013 and
dr laird and her laboratory uh develop novel data
analytic algorithms um neuroimaging informatics
tools and neuroimaging ontologies to yield
analytic strategies for improving investigations
into functional brain networks of healthy
individuals as well as populations with
psychiatric and neurological diseases and
disorders her research is currently funded by
several awards from the national institutes of
health and from the national science foundation
dr laird's presentation today is entitled progress
towards large-scale consensus based models of
human brain function contributions from fmr and as
always we are streaming this lecture live and for
reporting via youtube and if you are watching
on youtube thank you so much for joining us
also our specially selected 2020 2021 biomedical
data science innovation lab participants
are encouraged to submit any questions for dr
laird via the chat feature in their zoom sessions
i will synthesize these questions and i will ask
them on your behalf in the last 10 minutes or so
of the lecture and with that welcome angie
thank you so much we've been really looking
forward to your lecture thank you jack for the
very kind invitation thanks so much um for that
introduction i really appreciate being here and
and spending a little bit of time with everybody
um so just to get started uh as as you mentioned
i am an imaging physicist so so this talk is sort
of going to to center around functional magnetic
resonance imaging um i started grad school back at
the university of wisconsin and uh this was back
in the late 90s which was the early golden age of
functional mr research uh the medical college of
wisconsin in milwaukee was among the first groups
in 1991 to demonstrate the ability to image human
brain activation using fri with blood oxygenation
dependent contrast and and those years that was
an exciting time to be a physicist in wisconsin
so when i was a grad student in madison we
were riding the wave of those early successes
from folks like jim hyde and eric long and
peter bamatini and just starting to learn
um not just about task-based activations
but also rest of state connectivity and
there's a lovely little citation down at the
bottom a paper that peter banatini wrote that
kind of talks about this time so if if there are
any physicists and engineers in the audience who
haven't had a chance to kind of um take a look at
that and hear about that particular error i highly
recommend that you do so that it was uh it was
it was a cool time to be a physician in wisconsin
so with that as an introduction into who i am
and within my particular training um today what
i want to talk about is that here in 2021 cannot
believe it's 2021 i'm not sure what happened in
2020 but there you go um our broader scientific
community is rightfully focused on the current
reproducibility crisis and there's a lot of
development for amazing and innovative tools
and resources and best practices to ensure that
ongoing work in neural imaging in general and fmri
specifically is robust reproducible and reliable
those three r's right but looking back 30 years
ago even during that time when fmri was being
developed as an imaging modality a few groups
were early pioneers in looking at consensus across
studies and comparing activations observed across
multiple studies to determine where there was
agreement and when there was an agreement such as
in the case of the anterior cingulate cortex they
examine experimental design across those studies
and these two papers here being examples
of proto-analytic studies that focus on
somatotopic mapping of the anterior cingulate
cortex and in the first paper that i'm aware of
that was published in 1993 by tomas palace and
colleagues in that paper they examined various
uh functional pet experiments that required hand
responses speech and eye movements and mapped the
variability of responses across the singular and
this was followed by a similar effort in 1996 so
my point here is really to emphasize that we are
really embedded in this reproducibility crisis
but you know if you really look back
you can see that we have been interested
in reproducibility framed as consensus across
studies for for quite a long while now and so
um we know we've known pretty much from the
very beginning that there are limitations to
any single neuroimaging study such as small
samples right compared to other fields of
in cognitive and social science and particularly
clinical research neural imaging work fmri studies
you know really rely on the publishing of
relatively small samples which obviously can
have um far significant limitation and don't allow
a generalization another limitation is that fmri
in particular is an indirect measure of neuronal
activity and by focusing on the bold contrast
then you know we do need to acknowledge
that our reliability is limited by the
biological and technical and methodological
compounds associated with that contrast
another thing um that there's a lot of
attention that's it's being drawn to recently
is is the publication of isolated findings you
know we are all in a in a scientific culture
that it emphasizes innovativeness and emphasizes
being the first one to do things and so because
of the logistics and expense of fmi additional
experiments where you're just confirming something
that someone has already published and maybe
extending it just a little bit um you know there's
not so much an emphasis on that i think there's
a little bit of a culture shift that's happening
right now um but looking back over the past few
decades we really have a whole lot of literature
that's all about isolated findings and not so much
about confirming and replicating the cost studies
related to that is the real generalization
that we do of context specific findings and
here what we're saying is that we make a lot of
inferences about brain function and some sort
of half a mechanism that's based on a specific
observed difference between two imaging conditions
and you know given the way that our our our
field is sort of framed um this really is kind
of a stretch sometimes so um because of all
of these things we know that any single study
may have some limitations associated with that
but because of that there is an opportunity to
pursue meta-analysis to look at consensus across
studies so um all of this is is kind of a lengthy
leader to say that today we're going to be talking
about neuroimaging meta-analysis where we examine
consensus across studies by mining data activation
patterns that are reported in the literature
and one of the reasons why this is something
that is really taken off in fmri is because fmri
research generally adheres to two community-based
standards we spatially normalize our brains to a
standard brain template and when we report results
of any given statistical parametric brain image
such as what you see here for each cluster or
blob of activation we extract the centers of mass
or the peak locations and report those locations
in standard brain space as an xyz location
and so as a result a given peer-reviewed
paper is going to publish the picture
of the fmri activation patterns that you see
here on the right and that was as the results
of some particular task along with an accompanying
table on the left of what we call peak coordinates
which summarize those patterns and give you a
quantitative representation of the brain maps
produced by the study and so our literature
is chock full of these map table pairings
there's a lot of them you if you spend
any amount of time in the literature
if you know that these tables are very much
a community standard and they are available
in the pds of all the different papers that we
use and so from our early days we've really been
considering how these coordinates can be plotted
on the same map across study representing results
observed across many studies and so this was the
initial images that led us to the development of
algorithms and data analysis strategies for formal
quantitative and coordinate based meta-analysis
so one of the key things to consider is that when
i say meta-analysis um i don't mean that standard
effect size meta-analysis in which results are
pulled to determine if a statistically significant
finding is observed across studies um this type
of meta-analysis has in in some respects a sort
of complex history and in some cases some sort of
questionable practices that lead to in some cases
essentially p hacking a positive outcome um you
know i uh you can spend a little bit of time with
the clinical trials literature reading about a sex
seismic analysis and that's an interesting sort of
uh well to dive into but for today i want to
emphasize that what i'm presenting is a locations
affects that analysis which instead of asking is
there a significant effect across these studies we
ask of the significant effects reported across
the whole brain where do they converge so it's
that location emphasis here in the coordinate
basement analysis we ask where is the consensus
so there's a number of different coordinate based
uh meta-analysis methods that are available to
research but they all follow the same general
procedure let's walk through that and then give
you an illustration of it um if the first step is
to involve the foci with spatial kernel to produce
study specific model adaptation maps we combine
those model activation maps into a sample wise map
and then compare um to the null distribution
to determine box of y statistical significance
so an example is activation likelihood
estimate estimation i'm going to give you
that as a coordinate based meta-analysis method
it's a very popular choice so for illustrative
purposes let's let's kind of see what it what
it actually does the general approach here
is that each foci or set of coordinates
is modeled by a 3d gaussian distribution
we do the convolution to kind of you know
essentially blur those coordinates back to the
to the uh spatial blobs that they were extracted
from so for any particular set of coordinates
that you observe across the literature we can
do the convolution process combine those model
activation maps into a sample-wide map and then
threshold them based on statistical significance
so the idea is generally just to
take the coordinates blur them all
do some stats and then have a summary map
that represents consensus across studies
okay so beyond ale there are several other
coordinate based meta-analysis approaches that are
available to neuroimaging researchers and these
were nicely summarized in a 2017 publication um
and so if you are interested
in coordinate basement analysis
these are sort of your choices at this
point but then the second major category
the second major category of neurology
met analysis is an image based approach
and so in this case rather than
pool coordinates or peak foci ibm is
the statistical maps the actual result of
whatever um statistical analysis that was done
on your fmri data these have better spatial
specificity than p coordinates obviously and so
by combining these maps we ask where do the images
converge so uh various different image basement
analysis methods were nicely summarized in a 2016
publication um and then i'll also note here that
while image-based meta-analysis is preferred given
the additional information that maps offer us
compared to tables of coordinates image-based
meta-analyses are relatively rare there's only
a handful of them out there in the literature and
this is because a hardworking researcher can dig
through hundreds of papers harvest coordinates
from the tables do a coordinate basement analysis
but they can't just sort of magically
gain access to original statistical maps
those need to be made available by the original
authors and that's why at this point um
in the presentation i like to say hey folks
when you're drafting your name scripts please
go ahead and upload your maps to neuroevolve
these are you know whatever group activation
image you have or correlation analysis or resting
seed based connectivity analysis anything that
results in a brain map upload it to neural
fault cited in your paper and that helps with
folks who are interested in your paper being able
to go look and actually see your maps but also
downstream image based net analysis doesn't really
have a future unless all of us adopt this little
bit of data sharing into our publication pipelines
all right and then so as a little bit of a plug i
will say the previous slide listed a whole bunch
of different coordinate basement analysis methods
and image basement analysis methods and prior to
a couple of years ago those were all located in
different um different sources different code
different platforms and and in locations and
and i want to say let's see this is this is a
graduate student of mine named taylor solo he
has developed nightmare which is short for neural
imaging meta-analysis research environment it
is a python package that integrates all of these
different algorithms and methods for neuroimaging
meta-analysis and places everything in a common
interface um it's python based it's open source
we're very collaborative that if you're interested
in contributing to this package and joining
um this particular ecosystem that ties in with
night pipe my stats and nylon that we we welcome
everyone's contributions if you just want to use
meta-analysis then then this is the place that we
now recommend that you go since it is tightly
integrated with all of these other different
resources so um hats off to taylor for the initial
work he's done developing nightmare because it's
really been a nice step forward for the community
okay so that's all sort of an introduction to um
you know the topic of this talk which is which is
meta-analyses um and i i want to move now to give
you some examples of what meta-analysis possibly
can do for you and you know with this particular
start of this slide i could just tell you that
meta-analyses have gotten hugely popular you've
probably seen that yourself in the literature
i you know i tried to prepare a couple of plots
here that illustrate that point ale is one of our
more popular algorithms um and then neurosynth is
a coordinate based database that's designed
to facilitate coordinate basement analysis
or you can do a lit search or just by looking
for keywords of fmri placement analysis
and you can see that you know we're working on
increasing the number of papers out there on
these particular topics but what i think is more
important is to give you an example of you know
how this can be used and what sort of knowledge
might be gained from neurogenetic analysis
so the first example is a java psychiatry paper
from 2015. in this meta-analysis the authors
performed a coordinate basement analysis of
voxel-based morphometry or bbm studies that
examined gray matter reductions across six diverse
diagnostic groups that included schizophrenia
bipolar disorder depression addiction
obsessive compulsive disorder and anxiety
so this was a really large vbn med analysis
that included a 193 peer-reviewed papers
representing a total of over 7 000 patients
and over 8 000 matched healthy controls
now despite such a diverse diagnostic group they
found that gray matter loss converged in three
regions the dorsal anterior cingulate and the
bilateral insulin i'll also note that when they
examine diagnostic diagnosis specific effects
they found hardly any but they expect exception
of some distinction between schizophrenia
and depression and the other diagnoses and
to help interpret and give functional context to
these findings they then explore the task-based
and task-free connectivity of these regions
with a parallel series of data mining activities
first they examined meta-analytic co-activation
patterns using brain map which is another
coordinate based database and this identified
regions that consistently coactivated with each
of the common gray matter loss regions in healthy
participants during task-based activation studies
in in which we were not limited
to any specific task domain
and then second in an independent but parallel
analysis they investigated seed-based resting
state connectivity patterns in an existing
data set of 100 healthy participants for
each of the three regions of interest
that are shown in in the blue here
and then finally they summarize these results
and examine the conjunction between the task
based coactivations and the task-free resting
state connectivity patterns revealing a tightly
connected common neural substrate that included
the bilateral anterior insula dorsal anterior
cingulate and the thalamus and so we've started
referring to these um complex meta-analytic and
connectivity-based pipelines as metaconactomics
since we're incorporating tasks and rest clinic
tones from non-meta-analytic data to enhance our
meta-analytic outcomes okay so um in summary then
this work highlights the importance of the insula
and the acc as highly connected brain regions that
are linked to shared structural changes across
trans diagnostic psychopathological disorders
and um so this is a really well cited paper that's
a really good example of how meta-analysis can
really lead to a complex series of pipelines that
really further elucidate uh functional connectives
and then the second meta-analysis that i want
to highlight it's another jama psychiatry paper
and this one from 2017 and whereas the last one
focused on trans diagnostic structural alterations
this one examined fmri brain activations
during cognitive and emotional processing
in patients with unipolar depression so
not a whole bunch of disorders but just one
particular disorder and while the first example
meta analyzed results from structural studies
bbm studies we know that the fmri literature
is much more complicated there are a lot of
different tasks that researchers have used
to probe depression and each has its own
experimental design and analysis methods so here
we examine coordinate-based meta-analysis or
coordinate-based results from 99 experiments
reporting on over 100 depressed patients
and in this figure we show the red coordinates for
increased activations associated with depression
and blue as decrease activations again associated
with depression both for emotional in the top row
and cognitive the bottom row task so emotional
tasks on the top cognitive tests on the bottom
and when we meta-analyze these coordinates
we found no convergence not for any of the
specific groups according to meta analyze not for
the increases in activation not for the decreases
not for the emotional task not for the cognitive
task and i love this paper for two reasons
the first being that it's absolutely fabulous
progress for our scientific community to get no
results published in general psychiatry right but
also for what the speaker is actually telling us
we don't attribute our null results to a lack
of meta-analytic statistical power we know from
a previous paper that focused on meta-analytic
power that our sample was large enough and we had
sufficient power to detect even subtle convergence
effects and our conclusion here is that the lack
of convergence across fmri studies of unipolar
depression is likely attributed to a high degree
of heterogeneity across studies particularly
those that related to experimental flexibility
and that's differences in experimental
design and analytic procedures
so overall this work points to a really urgent
need for a strong focus on replication analyses
we need more of those in our community
particularly with respect to clinical neural
imaging rather than continuing to really focus
simply on designing um the the newer the more
complex new paradigms um new new ways of doing
things but to really kind of take a step back
and put an emphasis on replications and this
aligns with a number of current high profile
efforts to really shine a light on the strong
impact that methodological flexibility may be
having on our neuroimaging results
the most recent example of that
is the the narcs nature study that came out i
guess it was last summer or last fall where a
bunch of teams were recruited to all analyze
the same data set showing that methodological
flexibility actually has a really significant
impact on the conclusions of those analyses
okay so those are my two examples of what the
standard meta-analytic approach can possibly do
i like to highlight those because they're
nice compare and contrast set of examples
and now what i'd like to do is take a little
bit of detail but dig a little bit deeper
and show some more detail about how my
lab is further pushing this methodology
um and so to kind of set this up um i want to
highlight the fact that we you know are seeing
a lot of informatics development in the community
and that means more resources for managing sharing
and meta-analysis of neural imaging data and this
includes knowledge representation systems and
it was mentioned in the introduction that
i've done some work on ontologies which are
machine interpret interpretable languages to allow
computers to compare data across databases um and
the cognitive data descriptors are relatively
underdeveloped so even if you get a bunch of
scientists in the room to kind of list this the
subtypes of um tasks or paradigms that are used or
mental functions or constructs um you don't always
get a lot of consensus across groups that this is
something that it's not like we could just kind
of list different imaging acquisition parameters
that they're getting folks that agree on how
um which data descriptors we have to develop to
to annotate cognitive types of constructs is
really really challenging and has been so for
forever um so we put forward a bit of a of a
new approach using that analysis that asked the
question why not let the data facilitate consensus
and so the premise here is that differences in
activation patterns across a group of studies
should be captured and leveraged as they
potentially indicate meaningful segregations in
brain function sometimes it's the differences that
are what tells us something really interesting
such that tasks activating similar brain networks
should be grouped as functionally similar in
the cognitive schema and tasks demonstrating
differential activation patterns should be
potentially classified as functionally distinct
so the overall workflow here is um like with all
of these coordinate basement analysis approaches
the first step is to extract coordinates from the
literature so we put all these tables and pull
down a whole bunch of coordinates and generate
model activation maps um and so this is done
across a group of similar studies for whatever
construct you're you're interested in going after
these model activation maps basically take the
coordinates blur them up so you have an estimate
of what the original statistical parametric
look like a statistical parametric image looked
like and then you generate a correlation matrix
that compares all of these different activation
maps to each other so that we have a sense of the
similarity across modeled activation maps and then
we perform a data-driven clustering algorithm
on those modeled activation maps to identify
clusters of experiments with similar activation
patterns those clusters then can be grouped
and you can generate an ale map of those and
analyze the resultant metadata every particular
study can be annotated with metadata
that corresponds to the type of task
that was used in the experimental design and
the behavioral or cognitive domain of interest
that was isolated by the particular contrast
that generated the statistical parametric image
so here what uh i'll give you an example of this
we took a large group of face perception tasks
that were downloaded from the brainmap database
i believe there was over 300 individual
statistical parametric images that we had
coordinates for and we clustered them to obtain
four different clusters and what you see here
are the ale images that take those individual
clusters and meta analyze them to come up with
a consensus map of what the activation patterns
look like within each of these clusters now as i
mentioned every set of coordinates is annotated
with metadata that tells you about the type of
task what the participants did while they were in
the scanner and you can look at that metadata to
really get a sense of the trends um of which types
of tasks we're using in any given cluster and so
what we found here was that in the case of the the
first cluster the blue one here the the map really
uh resembled strongly the salience network which
included bilateral insulin interior cingulate and
the meta indicated that of the tasks that were
in this grouping there was a lot of emphasis
on visual spatial attention and visual motor
coordination to faces in terms of cluster two
um we saw the amygdala musical and face area
occipital temporal areas and the metadata
corresponded to perception and recognition of
faces for the green cluster we uh observe that the
the map itself resemble the default mode network
including medial prefrontal cortex and medial
precunious and the metadata uh corresponded
to a lots of social processing and episodic
recall of faces and then finally we had a
little bit of a red cluster in the middle
temporal gyrus and the bureau temporal cortex
typical and para hippocampal gyrus and the tasks
as revealed by the metadata corresponding
to face naming and lexical retrieval
this is great it's you know we did an analysis we
did some clustering we did some data driven stuff
but it's always important when you do data-driven
analyses you kind of take a step back once you're
done and really think about what you've learned
that's new and how your results really correspond
to the existing literature so we wanted to
ask the question how well do our results align
with existing um cognitive models of face
perception so we grabbed a really well-known
paper um that you know is sort of the very well
cited representation of the cognitive model of
face perception and we kind of dug into how that
particular model was pitched and we observed that
our purple cluster corresponded really well you
know we're referring to this with perception
and recognition of faces and in the governing
hacksby paper um there was a core system that
emphasized visual appearance of faces and and
posited regions that corresponded very well
to our purple cluster there is also an extended
system in this particular copy of the model
that incorporates person knowledge which
corresponded very well to our green green
cluster highlighting um involvement of the default
mode network as well as a little sub module here
that corresponded well to our red cluster of face
naming and lexical retrieval and then notably one
thing that was missing is is that we did see that
one of our clusters um you know focused on the
convergence in the salience network and really
involved this visual spatial attention component
and that was not really included in the could
be actually model and so in conclusion here we
were this was our first kind of go at this
and i'll show you in some subsequent slides
um how we've continued to work on this but
but this was sort of the first time that we
had taken this particular meta-analytic approach
and used it to confirm and extend a well-known
cognitive model of face perception where we
essentially confirmed with three of our clusters
this existing model and then extended it
using the additional salines component here
demonstrating that this large scale data mining
approach can really inform the evolution of
cognitive models by meta-analytically probing
the range of tasks that are included across the
literature and so then as i as i sort of alluded
to we've used this model a couple of times since
in in different sorts of application scenarios
the first was on face perception and then
in 2018 a grad student of mine king bottenhorn did
the same type of approach using naturalistic tasks
um in 2018 uh at the time a postdoc of
mine used this to examine emotional tasks
and then more recently we've looked at reward
tasks this is another grad student in our lab
jessica flannery and then we collaborated
with some folks over in germany
really recently to look at emotion regulation and
so it's been a real fruitful line of work to kind
of take this clustering approach in this large
scale coordinate based data mining approach to
really kind of dig into a particular construct and
really synthesize results across the literature
and so i'll say at this point that um i've been
in this meta-analysis game you know since the
very early 2000s and and staring at these
maps um you know for 20 years really
starts to reframe how you think about brain
networks um and so i've got here a a quick little
summary of all of these different maps that we've
looked at really recently from this clustering
based approach and i got to tell you that when
you sort of take a step back and look at the
results across constructs one thing that we really
noticed is that yeah across all of these studies
we see the salience network popping up we see
the default road network popping up we see the
central executive or frontal parietal network
whatever you want to call it popping up a lot
and you know this really aligns with um you
know our now accepted model of psychopathology
such that psychopathological processes
especially associated with mood disorders
are commonly associated with average connectivity
within and between salience network fault mode
network and the central executive network and this
was really laid out very nicely in a 2011 paper
by mennon that you know frames this as
the triple network model or the tripartite
network model that um you know does a really nice
job describing how the dysfunctional connectivity
in these networks can really lead to diminished
cognitive ability and diminish control over
self referential processes such as rumination
so this particular tripartite network model
is i think really important for understanding the
maladaptive network organization and function in
psychiatric disorders and it's certainly showing
up in so many of our meta-analyses um that are
both associated with clinical populations as as
well as healthy individuals these networks are
just simply very very important um so with that
i'm going to do a little bit of a transition and
um i kind of alluded to this just a second ago
speaking of these large-scale networks if you do
spend any time reading through the neural imaging
literature you'll nearly immediately see a variety
of names that all reference the canonical frontal
parietal patterns you know some people refer to it
as the central executive network the cognitive
control network the dorsal attention network
there's a lot of different names that folks are
using out there and we were really curious to see
if the current state of naming conventions
for these commonly observed brain patterns
is consistent or perhaps inconsistent throughout
the literature and if it is inconsistent then
we wanted to highlight that that's potentially
a big problem because that's confusing number
one to call different things the same name and
the same things different names um you know this
can limit our ability to coherently discuss and
interpret our community's collective findings
so while most of this talk has focused on
coordinate basement analysis this is an example
of what's possible with an image basement analysis
we thought that given we were given the fact
that we were really concerned about the spatial
specificity of the use of these different names
that an image basement analysis was the most
appropriate course of action for us to kind of
synthesize things across the literature and
explore whether the labels that authors use
when describing their network patterns whether
or not they consistently overlap with or are
clearly separable from different topographical
brain networks so that's my little intro there
we searched pubmed for papers that reported
spatial patterns with the corresponding functional
labels that are listed here and so that was a
very intensive literature search we focused on
studies examining data from healthy participants
between 18 and 70 years old that used whole brain
analysis methods we grabbed a couple of maps from
uh neurovault that folks had uploaded but for the
vast majority of the papers that we found we had
to email the corresponding author and ask for help
in in getting a hold of their maps um this was
a process that took many many many months and a
lot of follow-up i could write a paper itself just
on how you know lots of folks didn't have access
to the maps anymore lots of times we had to go on
a real extensive easter egg hunt with the authors
it required a lot of follow-up and that's what
i'm saying is it's you know image basement
analyses frankly they're preferred but they
are so much more work in getting the actual
data that you need to analyze um but in the end
we obtained 360 maps that were reported in an
original set of 188 publications um we took each
of those maps we re-sliced them we re-normalized
them to get them all to the same template and then
we performed a series of image-based meta-analyses
and what we found was that within a given label so
like for the group of studies that labeled their
maps central executive network no individual
network label map exhibited a correlation of
greater than 0.6 with its respective constituent
maps and that that's the solid line there
so within a label there wasn't a whole
lot of consensus between the labels so
comparing let's say essential executive
network label and cognitive control label
the average average maps for en fpm cen and wmn
those all exhibited a correlation of greater than
0.8 with the average of all the maps and then
the average maps of the van ecn tpn ccn and dan
had a correlation of less than 0.6 and so what
this means kind of shorthand summary is that
multiple different labels are being used to
describe topographically similar networks um
but with that with these uh the 0.6 result there
is some evidence for some distinct networks for
some of the other labels but for so many
of them um there wasn't much distinction
so then the question becomes are these all
actually the same networks so for this one
we threw all of the maps into a clustering
algorithm to look for clusters of similar patterns
and what this re revealed is that while the
label use is inconsistent hierarchical clustering
of the images themselves revealed four distinct
topographical clusters um and so with that
yeah with that you know the argument then is
that we as a field need to do a better job
in labeling our maps in a really consistent way
um so as as part of this paper that's currently in
review right now and available as a pre-print we
are sharing these patterns via neural faults and
we do provide labeling recommendations for future
studies um there is also right now an ongoing
um task force for the organization for human brain
mapping that i'm contributing to that's the ohbm
network nomenclature task force and that's a group
of individuals who all have extensive experience
in studying functional brain networks and
so we're trying to come up with a series
of community recommendations for how folks can
go about labeling their networks because as we
saw in this particular image basement analysis
there's not a lot of consistency and my feeling
really is strongly that if if we're not doing
a good job labeling things then that's going to
have downstream effects in how we discuss
and interpret our findings and so much of
the work that's being done these days is about
functional brain networks so it's really important
um it's not just interesting from an informatics
perspective but it's really important from
a community coherence perspective that we're
discussing things in a way that that's really
consistent okay and that is actually the end of my
talk so i want to thank everybody for their time
um i have an amazing group of folks that i
work with in miami we have a lot of fun and
we certainly don't get any snow in april so i
do want to thank everybody for your time today
and i'm happy to answer any questions angie thank
you so much for that that great presentation um as
people are trying to think of questions i want to
ask a couple so one of the things that is great in
my view about meta-analysis is not only can you
look for as you say synthesis across different
studies to look for common areas of activation
one of the things which is kind of cool about
meta-analysis is also incorporating information
about some of the study characteristics
and actually learning a little bit about how the
literature tells you what the literature tells
you about how these studies are done is that
something which is um kind of a focal point of
many meta-analyses or is that something that's
uh maybe not done in neuroimaging but maybe more
in other realms you mean the different types of
tasks i'm thinking of like different um like you
know proportions of males and females i'm think
uh as a as an element of a study um country of
origin like where was the study done um you know
magnetic field strength uh that kind of thing are
is there variance in reported results which are
based upon factors which are inherent in the study
so this leads me to my little um uh you know big
community porn where i want to say it really comes
down to our reporting standards one of the things
that is enormously frustrating about meta-analysis
is when you have this nice juicy stack of
important publications that have been out
there the variability associated with what people
actually report about is so high that it ends up
becoming hugely frustrating um i think that we
do have the potential to really look at so many
interesting aspects of variability as you
mentioned when it comes to participants
yes the sex gender issue also race ethnicity we
are and and continue to be a very predominantly
weird um uh uh field where so much of our
studies are are western educated industrialized
right i mean we don't have that um high
level of diversity and inclusivity in
our studies and and that and the origins are
that because so much of neuroimaging is hard
that once you get to the point where you're
recruiting participants it's like okay how can
i just get people into the scanner right so focus
on the technically challenging aspects of it um
that we haven't done as good as a job and making
sure that our studies are as diverse and inclusive
as possible um and i do think that analysis
gives us an opportunity at least algorithmically
in terms of you can do a meta regression where
you associate um you know your activation pattern
with some external variable associated with your
study whether it be your your sex gender ratio
or any of the number of things that you
pointed out but finding whether or not a
a particular paper or all of them have all given
you information about that thing it doesn't happen
there's so many critical details that get left out
of this paper or that paper um and that's why i
really like to also point out the covidas document
that ohbm published several years ago that give a
real clear guideline of when you are writing up
your paper please publish all of these things um
because it's really important for folks who go
back to do data mining the literature to make
sure that they have all the data that they need
and that's why i also like things like fmri prep
which these days they'll actually generate
an automated bit of text that's output
from the from the analysis that goes directly into
the manuscript and i know there's been a lot of
pushback from manuscripts and from from publishers
about whether or not that's plagiarism or not and
and that really gets a fire line under me because
i'm like we need consistency we need clarity and
communication and we need comprehensiveness of
all of this information so if there are ways that
software can help us do that you bet i think
that's the right way to go that's great and
you had mentioned um uh reproducibility um and
yeah you've talked a a lot about that and i i
think it's so important to be able to have
things like where you can look at a literature
from a meta-analytic point standpoint
and be able to make a statement about
what's reproducible and i guess that gets me to
things like statistical power calculations and
getting an estimate of what is you know how
often are we going to correctly reject the
null hypothesis um because so many studies
in the neuroimaging literature as you say
you've done all this stuff and then you're just
grabbing people who get in the scanner and you may
end up with a statistically significant result
but you've got a sample size of 12. you know
and i'm i'm curious if you have a comment about
how meta-analysis might be able to help us to
understand what some of the implications are for
our statistical power and our reproducibility
i don't know if i have a comment about
meta-analysis related to that i i do know
that my experience with abcd is really framing
how i think about that in in the sense of abcd is
the largest data set that i have worked with
yet i mean it's close to 12 000 participants and
um the only you know really larger one that i'm
aware of is uk biobank and you know a recent i
guess maybe a six-month-old pre-print
that's come out of washu's abcd group
is that you know the effect sizes for some of
the brain behavioral analyses and maybe cd are so
small um that i really wonder about
the plethora of um i'm sorry of um
studies that are out there with our really small
sample sizes and i have been spending you know
everybody's doing quarantine and pandemic
a little differently and i've been spending
quite a lot of time just simply thinking
about the future of fmri that if we need
these really large consortium-based studies to
find meaningful effects and and that's the key
word these days um and there's there's a really
cool adcb paper out there about meaningful effects
um but if if we need these really large multi-site
consortium what does that mean for a single lab
what does that mean for their future and and the
type of work that they're doing so i mean that's
a really good point you know if you need these
major multi-center collaboratives everybody using
the exact same scanner and exact same scanner
protocols and you're talking about sample sizes of
you know tens of thousands of individuals
to find this microscopic effect size uh
you know that is a very telling
those are expensive studies they cost
millions of dollars and very often they're going
on for a decade that's a lot of money and uh
activities that get soaked into that that might
not get down trickle down to the individual
investigator wanting to do their particular
cognitive activation task right right right
i mean i love the the small local lab like here
in miami we live in a predominantly hispanic
latinx community and so i personally am really
enthusiastic about pursuing studies where we look
at hispanic health disparities there's a dearth
of literature in this area and it's important
to highlight um you know different experiences
across the u.s so i'm really wanting to pursue
that type of work but i gotta tell you i do take a
step back and i try to think about how to align my
interest in that area with my feelings about power
and um and the ability to generalize and replicate
i don't have any solutions and it's definitely
something that's almost 90 states though
absolutely we have a question from one of our
uh participants um do you have a favorite meta
analysis methodology i do um so i was involved in
development of the ale method from the very early
days i am partial to ale activation likelihood
estimation i spend most of i mean all of the
actual meta-analyses that i've processed have been
ailment analyses um there's also two different
databases there's the brain map database of the
neurosim database and i have been spending more of
my time with the neurostim database lately because
it is it is larger than brain map um and so one
of the tricky bits is that if you use neural synth
you're sort of wed to the mkda analysis method and
if you use brain map you're sort of wed to ale and
and that's why i like to pitch nightmare because
nightmare kind of takes all of those different
things and puts it in a central python package
so now we get to do our preferred use case which
is to use ale in conjunction with neurosync data
what's the future of of brain map
i know that you've been sort of
uh disassociated with the day-to-day activities
for a while now but um you must have a vision or
thought about how that is going
to move forward because it's been
around for a while um it has been around for
a while right and so um for those of you who
who want the back story i was in san antonio for
a number of years and worked solely on the brain
map database but in 2012 um i was recruited by fiu
to to develop their cognitive neuroscience program
and so at that point i kind of stepped away
from brain map a bit and i'm relatively
agnostic at this point you know use whatever
tool resources is best for the current um case
um in terms of the future of both brain mapping
and neuroscience you know i'm i'm not really sure
i i i definitely think they you know they each
have their they each have their strengths and
their brain map is a manually annotated database
so they're actual research assistants on the
other end who are coding papers and putting in
the database and manually entertaining the task
and the behavioral domain and all the participant
information whereas neurosynth on the other hand
uses a web web scraper a tool to kind of scrape
all the coordinates from the from the uh html file
and and put it in there and so as a result there's
you know some errors associated with that and also
when a paper publishes a bunch of tables
of coordinates each representing a separate
contrast those all get lumped into one group
so strengths and weaknesses with both and um
i would hope that each would continue to go on
and exist because they are both really useful
tools for the community and i don't know if
you saw jack but tal just recently announced on
twitter that he is leaving academia to go work
for twitter is that so wow that's a loss wow
it is a huge loss so my understanding is that he
will pass his projects on i think to alejandra
vega but um you know this is the nature of this
right we have resources that are developed for
the community and we like to think that they
will exist um forever and sometimes there is
an evolution and we move on to the next thing
so maybe there's a next thing that's for sure
uh i can speak to that experience one thing which
is kind of interesting is the um uh very often
in the community and this is you know neuroimaging
has had its share of these but other groups or
other uh domains of neuroscience have done this
too where they have these kind of grand challenges
where for example there may be a common data
set and they just had one of these right where
common data set is thrown up and uh they say okay
everybody analyze it with your favorite analytic
method and then but send your results back or you
know share how you did it and share your workflow
and basically say what you did and then look
for commonality and consistency across different
groups using different methods and whatnot i'm
curious if perhaps there might be a meta-analytic
version of such a thing saying hey everybody go
and like look at the literature on working memory
for the past 30 years and do a meta-analysis of it
using whatever your favorite meta-analysis is and
basically putting ale analysis head-to-head
with something else in neuroscience or something
and looking for consistency or commonalities has
anybody ever given some thought to that no i don't
think we have and i love that idea angie this is
it we're going to be famous this is going to be
awesome i'm putting a link in the chat but for
those who aren't familiar with the narps paper i'm
linking you to the website there this thing was
amazing yeah very similar thing right here's this
data set there were 70 teams that came together
and full disclosure our site at fiu included one
of those um and just to see the different results
that you get when you basically say here's the
data but you go analyze it they gave us like nine
hypotheses to test i think um but full flexibility
as to whatever analysis method we wanted to do so
i mean if you're not familiar with nerds check it
out yeah i mean super important point this is
uh uh it's been a very topical thing in neural
imaging because uh neuro engine kind of gets
a bad rap about as we sort of discussed its
reproducibility so this was an attempt to kind
of like illustrate uh reproducibility and just
kind of the natural variation that exists between
groups analyzing the same data set i'm just kind
of curious if there might be a meta-analytic
version of this uh as well that could be a
future thing and you know you could tell people to
you know stick to a particular flavor of cognitive
domain um you know attention studies or visual
studies or i don't know whatever and get groups
to kind of analyze those literatures and share
their results that would be kind of intriguing
one of the things which is kind of interesting
and you didn't mention it i guess i gotta
uh ask about it is you know where
you have the coordinate based systems
obviously that's something which is and as you
say you can very quickly go through and look at
those coordinates create an al analysis
and get a sense of of what's going on
neurosynth and being able to look at the actual
maps is a little more challenging because you
just have those you have the maps which is great
but maybe you're you don't have all of them or i
don't know other reasons what about the real data
what about the actual underlying fmri time series
and other things that go into it and what are what
are some of the yeah because obviously going back
to the raw data is kind of a vital would be a
vital step uh what are your thoughts on that
um what are your thoughts on it i think you
could speak to this a little bit more clearly
than i could i'm just your humble i'm just your
humble host angie you know i'm spending more time
thinking about that because again of working
with abcd data um just because we're an abcd
site at fiu we're still held to the policies and
procedures for downloading abc data and analyzing
it just like any other site we're not allowed
to use our own local site we have to go through
um the nmh data archive so you know we have been
spending a good amount of time figuring out like
that's that's abcd is secondary data analyses
right there data is made available to the to the
whole community um it's different in that it's
all the same protocol once you start thinking
about um kind of trying to mine the literature but
doing it through raw data um then obviously you're
you're you're really coming from a place
where you're either considering um the open
neuro platform that russ boldreck has developed
which makes data sets available um or you know
i'm sure i don't need to tell you the enigma
model is becoming so popular across a variety
of different contexts um we've been spending
a lot of time with the enigma addiction group
and we are in the process right now of
conducting some resting state analyses
on data that was collected across a whole
bunch of different sites and there's not a
whole lot of harmonization in the protocol and
when you think about the addiction perspective
you are talking about how use substance use is uh
quantified and so trying to compare this set of
cigarette smokers to this set of cigarette smokers
to these alcohol users it becomes really really
important to really think about participant
use characterization um so you know you're
asking me to start with something really simple
coordinate-based meta-analysis and then kind of
go up a little to image-based analysis and then
go up a level to getting in the raw data and
with each level you just get so progressively
more complex it gets more powerful right because
you always want the absolute lost data that
you can get um and so you know the time for
the project starts mattering like you said having
a having a undergraduate or grad student sit down
and synthesize the literature and coordinate
basement analysis particularly if they're
working either through brain map or neural
synth is a relatively easy project we love
giving those to students it's a great way to get
introduced to neural imaging without all of the
technical challenges that come along with that you
don't have to teach them how to pre-process you
don't have to teach them you know the noise
removal and spatial normalization you can
just have them start getting thinking about you
know brain function location correspondences so
it really depends on what your goal is right as
always as always well i think we've reached the
top of our hour angie laird thank you so much for
a great talk and a really wonderful discussion
here at the end about all these different uh uh
pluses and minuses of meta-analytic data analytics
and uh what the in particular though what the
value is and how you can very quickly synthesize
the literature and get some understanding of
what's going on and uh clearly that's been
successful for you and hopefully um this will be
something that others will uh take a dive into as
well um so thank you thank you so much thank you
everybody who joined us and uh everyone have a
great weekend and uh we'll see many of you next
week thank you jay have a great time thank you